let's jump to this story we got from
newsweek
donald trump leads group around the golf
course during mysterious dc visits so at
first
there was this big conspiracy trump
shows up in dc he's wearing golf shoes
and a polo and they're like whoa whoa
whoa why is he not dressed up clearly
the only reason is that he's facing a
rest he was golfing they grabbed him
made him go someone then says these
leftist conspiracy theorists no no maybe
he's going to the hospital
maybe it was an abrupt trip he's got to
go to walter reed or something
some people were like dude maybe he's
going golfing
or i think the simple thing was like
sometimes people wear comfortable
clothing like he's wearing golf shoes
i don't know where sometimes he wears
suits sometimes you don't
so everybody was speculating nobody knew
and now we get the latest theory
here's a one of the this is a tweet with
107 retweets don the con man is in dc
quote golfing with kevin mccarthy devin
nunes eric trump sean hannity no golf
clubs how many guys does it take to help
trump find his balls ha ha so i don't
know what they're doing but there is
this photo that's going around i don't
know if those names are correct it said
kevin mccarthy but i don't know if he's
actually there what's the guy in red
holding that looks like a golf club it's
not a golf club i don't know what it is
but uh there are pictures of them on the
golf course in golf carts without golf
clubs
so the theory now is that these are
trump allies meeting in big open fields
with no devices away from recordings to
have a conversation i guess
and now the theories are once again uh
donald trump's gonna get arrested so let
me just say without further ado the
walls are closing in closing in
the the the end is nigh then is near um
the beginning of the end for donald
trump what else what what are the other
ones
bombshell report
republicans
republicans no i don't know about that
one but bombshell the walls are closing
in the end is near for trump this is the
beginning of the end
great this again part of me kind of
feels like they're not going to arrest
trump and they're doing all of this in
very high profile ways like the fbi
raids to put on a show to make people
think it will happen because the best
they can do
but at the same time you know i don't
know man what do you guys think you
think trump's having secret meetings to
discuss his strategy to avoid arrest or
plot a coup or what's he doing well if
if trump's uh arrested that's only going
to help people like desantis so i think
that also plays into the sphere of
what's happening here especially when it
comes to a lot of these central
controllers but also there's what 40 uh
indictments i think he probably wrote
subpoenas like sorry 40 subpoenas he
probably bought brought the boys around
to be like hey there's 40 subpoenas like
what do we do
i've heard some rumors yeah we don't
know what happened but but we can only
speculate from here i've i've heard some
rumors from
people close
close to trump's inner circle
that their conversations strategy about
you know whether or not they take this
seriously i want to be light on how i
phrase it because i don't want to play
those stupid games but uh you know i
wouldn't come out with an article and be
like definitively state this the media
likes to be like sources close to
trump's circle say x and it's like what
does that really mean so i'm just saying
it's a rumor that trump's you know
having conversations like doing to take
this seriously or not we're gonna move
forward and uh whatever that ends up
becoming i don't know but i think luke
is right he called the boys and said
guys 40 subpoenas we better have a
meeting about this
well i don't think it's illegal to to me
i mean the thing what the media is doing
is they're making everything that trump
does as if he's already a criminal as if
he's already been indicted as if he's
already been
you know proven guilty and so thing you
know like an ex-president playing golf
with his friends is not news but
whenever you you know write the headline
in such a way
you know people that you know
don't study this stuff you know like
like we do like they're they might be
susceptible to to
uh thinking that trump is doing
something so it's really a non-story but
if you put the right headline on it then
a lot of people might and it's all it's
also about just freezing trump like
we've been talking about like freeze
trump
keep people angry about trump keep
people thinking about trump trump's your
enemy trump's you know trump's going to
destroy our democracy trump trump trump
um and unless you you know are educating
yourself on how these you know these
deceptive tactics work then you might
fall for it but to me like everything
that we just saw is a non-story yeah
yeah like trump trump hangs out at golf
course breaking news it's like trump's
an ex-president like since when does an
ex-president not play golf with his
friends and since no golf clubs though
since when do a bunch of republicans not
talk i mean is it they're republicans
they're supposed to be strategizing we
gotta be democrats right i mean that's
the whole point you don't know who it is
yeah this person's claiming it's noon as
in they know but they're using a shot
that's making you think they don't know
who it is so it seems more
conspiratorial and more uh well i'm
saying this person on twitter doesn't
know who it is oh okay they're listing a
bunch of random names but you can't
actually see that well okay so you use
the word pounce earlier republicans
pounce because this is the one this is
the uh the verbiage that the left loves
to use and
you know meanwhile this is a prime
example of of the left pouncing i mean
uh it's interesting how they're
constantly
accusing conservatives of being
conspiracy theorists and you know
they're making everything a thing but
you know
they they are tweeting about how oh
they're having a meeting with there's
you know there's no golf clubs you know
i mean it's like it's like they're
trying to make something out of nothing
you know i mean so it's like it's very
interesting just the kind of hypocrisy
that's going on here well that's why i
wonder why should we take any of it
seriously you know i got like a
corporate press emailing me this is
really funny the washington post emailed
me today like right before the show and
they were like we have a list of people
who said that uh biden did not win the
election fairly and your name is
included on this list and i just started
laughing when i saw that i'm like okay
so i get the trump the diehard trumper
is calling me a cuck because i said
biden did win and trump did lose and
then i get the corporate press claiming
that i said the opposite this is just
absolutely amazing
why should i take any any of the the
corporate press seriously they're just
gonna lie they're gonna make things up i
can come on this show over and over
again and say that biden won because uh
people hated trump and trump supporters
you know they they can't believe it they
couldn't believe it and of course there
was the the shadow campaign stuff in
time magazine i'm not downplaying any of
that stuff but the media is going to say
that whatever they want no matter what
you do and they're going to find a way
to justify it they're gonna put out
stories like this for all we know you
know what i love i'm like the me these
people come out and they're like it's a
conspiracy trump's meeting no golf clubs
what's he talking about he's plotting
another coup and i'm like donald trump
sitting here with all his friends he's
like thank you for joining me gentlemen
this is an excellent investment property
it's going to be a time share golf
course trust me and that's like for all
we know he's meaning to sell property
it's like you got a bunch of friends
together we're going to look at a
building you're interviewed there's a
million and one reasons when people were
claiming he was going to the hospital
because he was dying they were like well
if he was dying someone would be would
be helping him and he's not he's not
being helped therefore it means it's
probably not a medical emergency and so
he's probably being indicted and i'm
like if he broke his wrist he would be
walking just fine there's a million in
one reasons you could make up as to why
trump went to dc yeah they just make
stuff up they go nuts with it if if only
there was this much media attention and
scrutiny on the world economic forum the
bilderberg group jeffrey epstein the
world would be a better place but no
we're still obsessing about donald trump
the corporate media's gift that keeps
giving they're obsessing about him i'm
sick of even just hearing about this
nonsense who cares he met and he talked
to people people do that all the time
you should see what what
corporations do with the politicians
that they buy and all the private
conversations that they have selling you
down the river but of course we don't
have that kind of media attention we
don't have that kind of scrutiny and
this is why in part we're dealing with
so many problems in our everyday lives
because of this nonsense that again is
just politics astray that is just
screwing people over no but you make an
actually an excellent point though uh
why are they not putting this kind of
scrutiny on the world economic forum on
themselves you know on themselves
because the thing is the fact of the
matter is that i know trump apologists
you know as as you put it um but it
makes you wonder are they in on the
agenda that
organizations like the world economic
forum are putting out probably and they
see trump and others like him as a
threat to their agenda and so of course
they're going to
demonize and try to in a sense uh
put this kind of focus and freeze
individuals who they see as a threat and
trump is just one of them i just want to
point something out too like this
picture that we have showing trump and a
bunch of people like sitting around like
standing around this empty golf course
i'm just imagining like what if trump is
speaking to them and he's like where the
golf clubs at the people the caddies
were supposed to bring them and now
we're standing here i'm so sorry
gentlemen and someone's like they don't
have golf clubs and it's like
how common is it
normal
for someone to be like it's going to be
15 minutes so the caddies get here i
guess they got held up
instead they go with this crazy
conspiracy trump's having secret
meetings and plots and whatever
it's like the most likely scenario is
they're waiting for golf well that's
what's going to backfire on them and it
always has historically i mean for them
to come after you right i mean you make
a point to be open-minded to do your
research but for them to come after you
it's like what that's not it's not
helping them right and it's not helping
uh you know your audience uh go their
way so i think that they over play their
hand yeah they they tweet things out
like this i mean there's a number of
reasons why they don't have golf clubs
like who cares like he's an ex-president
he's literally an ex-president he's
allowed to play golf and talk to his
friends or his constituents there's no
crime well here i think i think it might
have been cernovich who said i'm not
sure that
no no who said this someone said this to
us that this is the true crime podcast
for you know wine moms or like wine ants
and it's like the latest season of the
trump scandal like they actually have
true crime podcasts that sit there like
women talk about trump and what he's
doing so they need this they need it
she wrote yeah now mueller's gone and it
still exists
trump said cnn would kind of fail after
he was gone right i mean oh yeah they're
still talking like trump's literally
just hanging on mar-a-lago and that's
all they can talk about so it's you know
i i agree with luke i'm just kind of
exhausted like let's move on
you know you guys have the white house
you guys you have everything you want
why are you still hung up and you know
again it's like they're they're doing
more damage you know for their cause
than than good that's why i wonder a
shift to desantis would would work out
better because
then like i was saying before trump is
this this big powerful figure and he can
rally the left or the right desantis has
the right but the left doesn't care he's
not a celebrity they've tried smearing
him going after him but i'll tell you
man you
you have you seen those videos that
flecos puts out we talked about them
before the show for those that are
listening where it's like the dude goes
out of times square and asks people
questions and they're really dumb and
it's really it's really terrifying and
then you see those videos and you're
like now i understand bill gates anyway
you know easy
i don't understand bill gates
after watching those videos
uh if you go to those people and you say
what do you think about donald trump
what do you think those people are gonna
say uh racist bigot you know if you go
to those people and say what do you
think about rhonda sanders what are they
gonna say what does that mean who's that
like who's that
yeah have no idea so if you start seeing
a 2024 desantis run and trump is out of
the picture
they're going to try and be like
desantis is evil and people are like
who's that yeah you do trump and they're
like oh yeah trump f trump you know i've
been seeing videos though where they're
going into the inner cities and they're
going you know a lot of younger people
um they
miss trump they liked trump and
you know the thing is is that you know
trump was
part of all of our lives growing up
right i mean he's at home alone right is
everywhere and
so i think that really backfired which
is probably why he won
so again i think they've overplayed
their hand um and and americans i have
faith that americans are not as dumb as
you would think that americans are if
you if you're just following what the
news and what social media is telling us
yeah and that's an interesting point
justin because um trump from 2016 to
2022 or to 2020 he jumped four percent
in terms of getting the so-called black
vote
you know so he was gaining momentum in
terms of black people who are voting for
him and so
you know they obviously understand that
to the extent that hispanics and black
people are voting for
trump a so-called republican president
this is a very real threat and so you
want to double down you want to
mobilize all of your radio personalities
i mean if you listen to
any black you know urban radio program
on a morning radio show they're
constantly demonizing trump even though
he's not in office and so they're
constantly mobilizing you know a lot of
these urban and hispanic
radio and television personalities to
constantly perpetuate this message of
you know trump bad trump bad trump bad
leading up to the midterms thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you